- I feel like I'm in
a 70's porn right now.
(laughing)
(gentle instrumental music)
- Today, we're at the Hollywood Roosevelt
trying on competitive swimsuits.
- These are the same
ones that Michael Phelps,
Ryan Lochte, all those guys wear.
- I've a feeling it's
gonna be bit of a struggle.
- I'm a big dude, so
I'm expecting some flabs
to kind of spill over.
- I fully expect to
put on on this swimsuit
and become a mermaid.
- I read about the
swimsuit, and it says that
it constricts our muscles.
So I don't know how that
actually helps you swim faster
but we'll find out today.
- Hey.
(dramatic instrumental music)
- This is my suit, and this is me.
My arm.
Not my leg, my arm.
- This is one of my legs.
- Just wow.
- This doesn't feel stretchy at all.
- Like a Superman outfit.
- Here we go.
(ticking)
- This is really hard.
(groans)
- I cannot get this over my ass.
(ticking)
- This isn't going anywhere.
- We might need scissors.
- My butt is just way too big
to put anything over that.
(ticking)
- Just leave me here to die.
I'm done.
- I'm losing circulation
from my knees down.
- I want my mom.
- Throwing in the towel.
I'm giving up.
I tried for 35 minutes,
it ain't happening.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- I'm having trouble breathing.
Can't wait to get this off.
- It was stuck trying to get over my ass
for about 30 minutes,
at that point (groans)
it just ripped.
- Feels like it's gonna
pop off at any second.
- So glad I ripped it,
because I can breathe on one
part of my body now.
- I feel like, kinda like
Captain America right now.
I look great, right?
Let's go race.
(gentle instrumental music)
- You (beeps) fast.
(groans)
(laughing)
- Overall, the experience
was memorable and miserable.
- Honestly you could make a Saw movie
out of all of us trying
to put on these suits.
- Felt like I was gliding
through the water,
as opposed to fighting my way through it.
- I bow down to Olympic swimmers, truly.
They're my heroes now.
- [Voiceover] Taking it off.
- Oh, yes.
(laughing)